la grande rue jean pierre duclos
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
or
il s'est déguisé à la fouine jean-pierre
ce que je propose avant de le faire avec
la belle qui avait vanessa j'aimerais
que tu le fasses avec un membre de
l'équipe pour monter ce que ça donne
d'accord je vais je vais choisir
allez il l'a jamais fait dont peut-être
on va faire jean michel maire c'est
toujours un succès alors vous saignez
oui les non-dits bafouilla d'accord
sinon j'essaie de bien me positionner
attention ce sera un âge rappelle aux
téléspectateurs mais ce qu'il ne dit ni
oui ni non pendant une minute
et si jean michel maire le fait j'offre
10 places de cinéma un peu de cash tag
tp est malade c'est paris pas en face
des appareils photo enfin c'est plutôt
la tension gardes d'ouvrir le pupitre
des réunions sont immédiates
attention près tu essaies partie bonjour
comment ça va très bien jean pierre elle
ensuite les téléspectateurs des jeux
novateurs souvent de s'étaler sur quelle
chaîne sur france 3 la 3c ça exactement
c'était en noir et blanc et en couleur
aux couleurs déjà exact comment
s'appelle le juge-arbitre femme a dit je
ne crois pas tu es sûr a dit moi et
après tu regardes etc temps après après
c'était un incident m'a pris sur l'a31
téléfilm un téléfilm ne me fatigue pas
du tout ça va très bien et qui va
peut-être dédié tu es content j'espère
pour égaliser le chat parce que tes amis
te regarde à la télé ce soir tous ceux
qui voyaient tag anonyme et lino ils
vont maintenant je veux dire pas du tout
certain je t'emmerde riez
[Rires]
je le
attention on ne doit pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
foot renvoie
un sachet nous a pas prévenus de sa
nouvelle fonctionnalité à l'esnam r +
moi franchement j'ai mis du chien chichi
là on lui dit qu'il a au le fait-maison
thibault a tranquillement passé du
politique je n'en avais pas pensé vous
pouvez presque déjà dur si oui où la
baisse et les chiens à oui quand même
ils cherchent ils à un chat qui
[Rires]
l'on pourra faire sans la projection
pour personne la projection
l'envié c'est allez on y va on y va on
éclate avec hydro québec avec 10
rebelles avaient jamais avec québec a
pas vu l'aura sera jugé en moi tu fais
pas là déjà parce que je sais que c'est
qu'il avait des saloperies que le vêlage
ça a été trois je ne fais pas s'il te
plait je suis sûr parce que
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la raison en est qu'elle est la raison
je fais juste le co2 tco2 attend face à
temps mais on s'en fout mais cette fois
face à l'épaule et de permanence ans est
particulièrement bien des cons je vous
aime beaucoup vous savez ça à temps
c'est pas parfait mais c'est parfait je
vous aime beaucoup
je suis très content de ce bras pour
garder les jeux de 20 heures les jours
générale vous participez parfois la voix
j'étais chez ma mère on a mangé là ils
vont regarder après les jeux je
cherchais moment chez marvelous à vous
habitez paris
j'habite paris tout à paris même paris
même on s'écoute bien dans paris et
seulement on circule bien nom pareil tu
sais pas si cool mais qu'ils soient pas
respectés ont répété je ne répèterai
plus jamais tu produis je le promets tu
crois que jamais elle va réussir et cela
a été répété toi je dis oui ninon jamais
répéter avec des copains mais la fouine
j'étais sûr que non
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
jamal debbouze à ton tour taquet de
nantes accueille non non vous respectez
la loi vous les orientez jamel mais le
met le comme ça mais ça sort d'où la
plume et le co2 mais bien fort
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est déjà bien que tu regardé l
essaimage de moteur alors en tant que le
génie on va se compter aux j'ai 40 ans
en arrière est d'accord ça vient donc tu
regarder en famille les jeux de 20
heures exactement étaient appelées
beaucoup de monde et que les jeunes
matin une flopée de mots pendant féminin
masculin oasis en duo ils ont dit une
bien tes contrat de redonner la bonne
réponse
je suis très content on a tous épatés
passionné l'a absolument pas tu me
manqueras pas je n'ai rien dit ça va on
recommence le jeu vous voulez ça va tu
es coût de la maintenance sur table de
la faute au tir et je suis 13 ans et
sans vous qui posez des questions parce
que c'est bien de contrat serait
difficile parce que c'est historique
pour moi c'est un guichet dateur
commence intelligente mais têtue comme
une chaire litres juge-arbitre faut
valider mais je suis à plus de soutien
de l'uqam est lourd maître capello
maître capello sera exactement dit
d'accord avec ta fille voulait l'aider
je crois que ça m'a pris son prénom elle
s'appelle lilas te regarde sur sur mila
elle me regarda l'a vu à la télé
millions
[Applaudissements]
je
est ce que vanessa ce que tu veux faire
non ici c'est honteux c'est repenser le
moose n'a pu dépasser je gagnais pas si
je gagne ma vie
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ces nouvelles américaines
est ce que vous voulez alors attendez et
chats c'est extraordinaire ça c'est la
dictature à detroit lundi que non
jean pierre ne rien vous alors tu me
regarde bien dans les yeux regarde pas
la caméra un choix bien me regarder dans
les yeux et bref les mecs si je gagne
ici je gagne et calories les calories et
latine
c'est pour ça qu'on s'en fou rigole un
peu loin at en fait je m'approche le
bond du bas-rhin et scriptum des pop up
bonsoir alors tu as beaucoup d'amis ce
soir avec toi
aller à fond
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]